this is a production of cornell
university
all right thanks so much hopefully
everyone can uh can hear me all right
um well it's it's uh it's great being
here uh i wish i could have been there
uh in person um so hopefully this goes
well and i have a chance to
come back
um
so uh like that great introduction by
george um i am a professor of biocystics
and a senior researcher at microsoft
research in the biomedical machine
learning group
just as a quick background for everyone
who may not uh be familiar with
who i am um
i i
think about our current research name
uh in my in my research group as one
that we take modern computational
approaches and we try to develop theory
that enable their interpretations to be
related back to classic genomic
principles so so one thing i like to say
is you know uh
we don't just take or or try to find uh
build really fancy hammers and look for
nails we should really care about the
specific biological questions um and
we've tried to build specific hammers
for that for those given questions
um
and so
one theme across all the projects and
and the stuff that we have on going on
lab this idea of like modeling variation
across complex traits and we do this
over complex traits and a lot of times
we think about this in human beings and
other model organisms um and this can be
this idea of setting human height i also
do have this other part of my research
program that does things about not only
how to model genetics information but uh
proxies for genetic information so this
idea of modeling shapes
across a
different species so here we have uh
finch beaks and and uh
heel bones from from different primates
i'm gonna talk about this today but i'll
touch on this a little bit at the end of
how these methods that i'm present today
can be used for some of these
applications
um and so what i say about dissecting
phenotypic variation we like to build
statistical models um where we think
about phenotypic variation as being an
entire piece of the pie right
and this pie can be broken down into a
combination of genetic and environmental
effects
now we like to focus on this genotypic
variation portion um where we like to
dissect this into additive variation so
you can think about this idea in the
cystical model as being gene a's effect
plus g and b's um as well as taking into
account these nonlinear uh um pieces of
pie as well so you can think about this
as effective gene a times the effect of
gene b
um
my group thinks about the genetic
portion as being like an epi
statistical epistasis here so you can uh
we'll focus this on this gene by gene
interactions but of course it's
nonlinear component it can also be a g
by e as well and a lot of methods that
i'll present today
can be extended to those application
areas
and so the data description for stuff
that i'm going to focus on in this talk
or you know we could think about this is
we'll have some continuous trait vector
y this could be anything from crop yield
again to human height
um
body mass index
and then we're going to focus on our
their inputs for these algorithms on
being genotypic data so like this uh you
know the snip chip so so uh every cell
here being coded is zero one or two
based on like some minor little
frequency
um
and uh you know a big part of our
statistical program at least when we do
in physical genetics for humans is we
think about linear models being well
suited for trait mapping okay so uh
going back to stat 101 uh you know we
have some uh trait we have our
high dimensional genotypic vector here
you know for humans a lot of times we're
thinking about you know we're studying
over hundreds of thousands of
individuals um millions of snips
um that what i really want to focus on
this slide is this beta term here and
we're going to focus a lot on this beta
term where beta each beta j for every
single snip kind of lends some notion of
evidence or association for that given
marker right um and with these beta js
after i do you know some um ordinarily
squares or the case might be these beta
j's can now lead me to be able to do
things like hypothesis testing right and
that's really really important in our
schemes because hypothesis testing leads
to things like p-values uh significant
measures then we can then go downstream
and do further analyses with right
um and so you know probably everyone in
this room is very familiar with this but
just in case everyone's not you know we
have we can take these p-values and then
have these manhattan plots right where
we have the chromosomes on our x-axis uh
the negative log transform p-values on
the y-axis and the spike here might mean
enrichment in that given genomic
position original implication you can
then go in and investigate you know
which uh genes might be in certain
coding regions and that sort of thing
um so you know i've i've done a few
ideas about how to extend these models
not by looking at just one trait but but
many traits um and how to how to
leverage the correlation out of crop not
just across snips but also across um
phenotypes in order to do better genomic
selection and better prediction for
different complex traits and diseases um
so a recent um paperwork just came out
with a with a really good friend of mine
dan renshi at uc davis was thinking
about this idea of leveraging um that
correlation structure um in order to uh
improve upon the state-of-the-art models
in this field
um this is our recent papers came out
genome biology using uh this method
called mega lmm
we can actually study hundreds of
thousands of traits at a time at any
given time um and have that scale quite
well as the data sets get larger and
larger
now a big portion of my group is to move
away from linear models okay so um my
group actually thinks about how to use
machine learning for a lot of these
given association mapping based tasks um
you know for a lot of people that are
probably aware you know machine learning
uh are pretty well suited for prediction
based um uh
studies
um but unfortunately a lot of these
methods are also referred to as being
black fox and what i effectively mean by
that is
uh you know we typically have some
output in these are input in these
algorithms some sort of data
the data defenses algorithm and then out
spits a really nice prediction
but you don't necessarily understand or
have a very clear view of what's going
on inside these algorithms in other
words this idea of um the classic idea
of hypothesis testing that i showed in
the linear model case is kind of lost
right
um and so a really big research goal for
for my research program is to provide
interpretable ways to summarize
how these input variables are being
uploaded or downloaded in order to get
these really nice predictions right like
trying to figure out how this algorithm
is summarizing the importance of these
variables in the context of these really
nice predictions
um and so here i think about the inputs
being genotypes and then the outputs
being phenotypes okay
now to kind of tie this all back in
together
um of a linear versus black box model
regime you know on the left hand side we
have linear models where again
hypothesis testing is really well
characterized the issue with linear
models is that i only see a portion of
the pi right linear models can only
model additive effects and as a lot of
us are very aware you know a lot of
complex traits and phenotypes have a big
significant proportion of non-additive
variation that play a role in the
progression of these uh
diseases
um black box models see or machine
learning methods or nonlinear regression
methods however you want to phrase them
they see the entire piece of the pie
right so they can leverage um things
like activation functions and nonlinear
kernel methods in order to see the
non-additive variation that also might
be playing a role in the context of
these uh
these traits and phenotypes the issue is
i can't necessarily do hypothesis
testing on the right hand side like you
can do on the left-hand side
so a big another way to restate my
research goals are to work with models
on the right-hand side while giving them
the interpretability that i normally get
on the left
and so a conventional wisdom of thinking
about this in statistics is you know
smooth non-linear functions like we
would get used in machine learning
neural networks whatever the case might
be um are often more predictive than
linear ones but variable selection is
much easier uh with limit in the context
of linear regression
the conventional wisdom about this in
genetics is that nonlinear models are
typically better for things like genomic
selection or fiends of prediction
but the use of
linear models for things like g watts
and qtl mapping is much more standard
and so i think about the components of
the interpretable model as being
a mixture of three things
one you need a motivating probabilistic
model
uh two you need a notion of an effect
size so a a regression coefficient or a
weight that tells you uh you know
in some magnitude way
how relatively important effectively
each skim and marker is in the context
of predicting or understanding some
phenotypic variation
and then i want a statistical metric
that summarizes the significance of each
of those markers right so i don't just
want to wait but i also want something
like a p-value that tells me which of
those weights are worth me following up
on
okay
so i'm going to start by
in part one kind of going how we do this
and think about this in my group from
two different ways
the first way to do this is by via post
hoc method okay so what that effectively
means is i fit some complex uh model and
then i try to figure out after i fit
that model what that model has learned
right so the mod is gonna give me some
kind of nice predictions and i go
backwards and figure out okay which
snips or or which markers uh were most
important in making that really great
prediction
so here i'll define what we call an
effect size analog and i'll give you a
way that we think about a nice um what i
think is an intuitive
uh post-hoc measure for determining
importance and then we'll talk about
simulations and data real data examples
there
the second way we've been thinking about
this recently is to use what we know in
biology to govern the architectures that
we place in these non-linear machines
right so effectively we uh allow our
model to only learn
what we think might be plausible in the
context of certain some type of genomic
structure okay so here we define these
as biologically annotated neural
networks um
these are uh i think also really
intuitive and i think they would apply
to many different areas that people are
working on particularly in this
department
um
here we have and then i'll talk about
how we fit these kind of models and also
give you some idea of some uh simulation
studies and method comparisons there
so let's talk about these post hoc
methods first
um and so you know
taking a step back from linear
regression i had this x beta term where
i said these betas uh are used to then
use uh derive
uh really nice p values and significance
measures for uh association mapping my
group is going to relax that uh
assumption okay so instead of this x
beta i'm just going to assume that my my
data has some non-linear type of
structure some f of x term where that
structure um not literally is is driving
the the variation of my phoenix hype y
right
and so uh this this non-linear structure
can take a lot of different forms i'm
going to be a little busy about it i'm
going to put a prior on the types of
functional forms that this that my
relationship between genotype and
phenotype can take
um using what we're going to call a
gaussian process
um
you can you the gaussian process can be
defined by two different terms one is a
mean function here we're going to assume
that that mean function is going to be
zero the key though here is what we're
going to call a covariance function or
similarity function measure which is
that k term
you can think about this as being a
covariance or like a relationship matrix
between
all everyone's genotypes in my data set
in linear mixed models we assume that's
like an additive thing right this xx
transpose type of
kinship
here we're going to assume in the gp
context that can be any kind of
non-linear measure okay so not just some
not not something that's just strictly
additive i could place something like a
gaussian kernel on this so instead of
measuring the additive relationship
between uh observation one observations
to uh genotypes will have a non-linear
measure instead
and this is going to give me a lot more
flexibility to model again that
non-linear portion of that pi that i
showed earlier
and so the key thing about these
non-linear kernel models that's actually
really cool is you have this really nice
kernel trick that's available but the
kernel trick can also have an issue with
it if you're if your goal is not just
prediction and your goal is also to have
some kind of idea of interpretability
so i can start my not my high
dimensional snip space i can define a
kernel function which effectively means
that i can model things with this
non-linear f
right i get really nice prediction in
what we call a function space
but the problem is if i if i want to now
understand okay what did this model
learn in the context of my data you know
there's no way to kind of go from
function space back to snip space right
and so the classic idea of variable
selection is lost in these models right
kind of something that i was alluding to
before
and so i have a nice
motivating probabilistic model but once
i fit this non-linear function how do i
get this idea of an effect size or an
effect size analog
in this nonlinear framework
and so let's take another step back and
think about how we do this in in linear
models right
so in linear models i typically have um
some linear uh
linear assumption
the way i derive an effect size estimate
for these betas is i project my y
my my phenotype onto the column space of
my data right this gives me a nice beta
hat and this beta hat is what i use to
derive p values with okay um
one standard projection that we assume
is kind of like this generalized inverse
at the bottom
now what we created with with our own
group is we said okay we can i derive
like an analog with our own nonlinear
models right so instead of this yx beta
term now i have this f instead
instead of projecting y onto the column
space of x i'm going to project my
smooth non-linear function onto the
column space of x okay
and that's going to give me what we're
going to call an effect size analog for
every snip
okay so i'm not just modeling this
additive proportion things i'm going to
have the smooth nonlinear um
function that i projected on and that'll
give me like a overall association uh
weight for each of my sniffs in my data
center okay based on the nonlinear
function that i learned
and just to make things completely uh
similar here we'll assume the same kind
of projection that i would have done in
linear homelessness okay
it's actually really nice because i can
now fit this kind of this kind of steam
of of deriving an effect size analog in
almost any kind of model that i fit
right so i'm gonna i'm going to duke so
i'm still gonna be coldly basing about
the way i think about fitting models um
let's assume we have some some
bayesian model here where i have priors
on things um
i'm going to fit this with like what we
call an mcmc sampler so every time i'm
going to sample from these posterior
distributions to get estimates for every
parameter in my model
if you notice in the third step what's
really nice is anytime i see a new
observation or realization of f
i have an explicit function that will
map me back to the
column space of beta tilde right so it's
allowed me to to derive also estimates
for these effect size analogs that i
would not have normally gotten um
uh without this kind of projection setup
right so i now have these beta tildes
which tell me now how every snip
is being uploaded or downloaded by that
gp that i fit earlier okay
and then the same thing that you can do
with with regular models you can also do
this effect size analog so once i have
these effect size analogs i can take
them and do predictions with them
whatever the case might be
downstream
okay
so now i have not only a probabilistic
model but i have an effect size analog
now the the the shortcomings of this
analog are
the last step so i now have these
weights for every snip in my data set
but i can't necessarily derive a p value
with them right i don't get nice
standard errors um in basic statistics
we have this thing called the posterior
inclusion probability which is the
probability that any of these models are
you know these uh features are enriched
for a given trait or given output i
don't i can't necessarily derive those
there's no nice um
theoretical setup here other than the
fact that i've projected back onto my
original input space
and now i'm looking at these these
weights
so
the recently what we did is think about
okay once i have this collection of
weights how do i now figure out a nice
way to rank them so that i can tell like
an experimentalist these are the things
that you want to follow up with first
now the way that i've thought about this
um is via sports and we've come up with
a new measure to kind of do this um and
i'll get to the math in a second but
let's think about this intuitively
really quickly
so let's say we have a sports team
okay
um
now the sports team as a collection
uh is going to have some kind of
identity right as a network right and
that group is going to win a certain
amount of games right
now the way i can figure out who the
most important player is in my network
is i can individually take each of these
players and put them on injury reserve
right so let's see let's see one at a
time each of these players are not
playing okay for instance let's just
take number 30 there in the corner
and let's say that he's no longer
playing
now without number 30 on the team i
might lose some games but the overall
structure or information within my
network
might be relatively well intact right
now let's say i take another random
player and i put him in injury reserve
or he goes and shoots space jam or he
goes inside he wants to be a baseball
player
without that individual on the team i
like lose a lot more information with
him not being around
right so the way i can do this if i
could do this on every single player i
can measure the distance between my
information i had in my full network and
the information i've lost with the
network with that individual not being
around on the team anymore right and
that distance will tell me relatively
speaking how important each player is in
summary order right
now we could do this with genes and
snips or any kind of
genetic component as well
and we can do this by measuring the kl
divergence here um
after we fit these models right so i get
these beta these these effect size
analogs the way i can do this now is
study the kl divergence between every
single snip
being included in my network and each
snip being conditionally out of my
network right
and so we're going to measure the
conditional distribution with that snip
being that snips effect being set to
zero and the marginal distribution with
me having included their information in
the network okay
and so the kl divergence of zero can be
interpreted as
um
a variant not being a key explanatory
variable relative to the rest right if
that distance doesn't move anywhere that
means i don't really need that variable
in my model in order to explain um
this variance this variation of this
complex tree right
in other words the k other versus zero
if and only if those two distributions
are zero or equal sorry
now we did we took it one step further
and thought about okay well how do i
think about this from a null hypothesis
perspective okay so what we do is we we
fit our gp we get these uh effect size
analogs
we do this kl divergence for every
single snip in my data set and then what
i do is we scale
each um
each kl divergence
by the sum of all of them
so that they're all they all sum to one
right so the the entire information in
my data of all of my genes collectively
sums to one
um what this effectively means is it
gives me a really nice null hypothesis
to work with
so the null hypothesis of rate is a
little different than the null
hypothesis you might do in basic
statistics okay the null hypothesis in
this rate like measure this relative
centrality measure
is
under the under the null where i have um
no signal
i'm effectively saying that every single
variable is about the relative
centrality is about the same meaning
that every single variable is about
contributing about equally to the
variation of my output right
the alternative is that some variables
are contributing much more than others
going back to my basketball analogy
the null hypothesis i have a team a
bunch of just a bunch of bench players
right
and the alternative is that i have a few
stars
okay so that one over p line is going to
serve as like our significance threshold
here
okay
so let me kind of show you how this
works in practice
so let's say i have a a data set with 2
000 samples 25 genetic markers
i'm going to specifically choose the
last three markers to be causal so those
are going to be my uh jordan pippen and
rodman in my basketball scenario
um we're going to consider the following
architecture so uh some of these all all
of my three variables are going to have
um both have additive effects as well as
interactions between them
i'm going to assume very uh loosely just
for a proof of concept that the braz
inheritability of this trick is 0.6
and then we're going to perform
association mapping using rate
okay
um
so here's how the results look
so i run my gp i fit my effect size
analog and i've derived these rate
measures for every variable as you can
see the model you i correctly identifies
uh jordan pip and robin as being the
most important variables all other
variables
are not seen as important according to
this y-axis this rate measure
that one over p i was talking about is
that dotted line
um and so let me kind of show you what
happens when i was saying like what
happens when i have only bench players
on my team
so what i can do here is i can say okay
i'm going to put jordan on injury
reserve and i'm going to put everybody
else also in i'm going i'm going to run
this rate measure again right so jordan
is no longer being considered his effect
is always set to zero
so if i do that
and run this rate measure again
what you see is that the model still
identifies pippin and rodman as being my
most effective players
um but really interestingly the value or
the relative centrality value of the
rest of the data of the rest of the
features in my data has gone up
an analogy here thinking about this is
like i've lost 40 points a game so
somebody has to step up somewhere right
i no longer so the the idea of what
information is left is is uniquely
spread across all the other noisy
variables right i can do the same thing
again
um where i take out now pippin rod
missile is identified as a star but i
have a then you can see again the rest
of the variables has pinched upwards
i can remove rodman the same thing
everyone's kind of hovering around this
like almost like a null distribution
of um
our uniform distribution of importance
as a proof of concept i can say okay
what happens if i
uh
removed number 30 instead of jordan
instead well you can see well i still
uh come to the same conclusions
you can also say what happens if i just
simulate data from complete noise
well you see everyone kind of hovers
again around this like null distribution
this like one over p type
line so let me kind of show you how this
works in practice for for uh uh this
mouse data set
uh from the welcome trust center for new
genetics here we have approximately 2000
related mice um each mouse has been
genotyped for 10 000 snips
um i really like this data set because
you have 129 different traits that have
been separated into six broad groups
behavior diabetes so on and so forth
what's really nice about these is each
of these
categories have varying different um
architecture breakdowns in terms of how
much of their variances can be
contributed to out of effects and how
much of this variation can be attributed
to like um nonlinear interactions
um we'll just focus on one for the time
for the time being uh
um but um we'll compare fitting a gp to
this trait with com with fitting like a
single snip g watts that we typically
use in uh engine x
and so here again we have another
manhattan plot on the bottom is the
single snip test right you can see the
chromosomes on the x-axis again uh
negative log transform p-value on the
bottom the rate values will be at the
top
stars are genomic regions that have been
validated from previous studies um and
you can see how with nice resolution you
know chromosome one is basically a spot
that's been identified by a mini uh
linear mixed model based methods and so
you can see the additive effects kind of
nicely uh correspond between both
methods
but but areas like chromosome 11 and 12
where there's a lot of non-additive
variation that happens between these two
genomic positions you can see um how
nicely resolved
the gp is able to identify that with
rate versus like things are a lot more
noisy when looking at the single step
test
um
again i always like to show the slide
because i think this also helps motivate
why you might want to think about and
consider non-added or non-linear models
in in
association based mapping tasks
um
you know again these are 129 different
traits i did a variance component
analysis to kind of show the breakdown
across um different types of order of
effects and you can see if i look at
additive effects they're going to be at
the top you have pairwise interactions
their order interactions and then this
idea of common environment reactions
with genetics
and you can see how uh
very rarely at least in this status that
does this additivity kind of dominate
the phenotypic variation you can see a
lot of these uh um phenotypes
there's some nonlinear component that's
driving this variation across this
across these different mice
and so i just use this as like a nice
example to show that there is some
utility here
and so that's that's one uh that we that
we use to think about uh post hoc like
how to deal with these things now now
rate's not perfect right um rate's a
nice nice model and the rate works
really well for these kind of
smaller examples where you have you know
2 000 mice 10 000 snips as that number
of snips goes much higher that one over
p line becomes not as useful anymore
because as p goes to infinity that
number gets closer and closer to zero so
that they have like what is significant
anymore becomes a lot more hazy and so
there is a finite uh
place where this gp and rate thing is is
incredibly useful
um so that got us thinking about okay
you know post hoc methods can get us so
far in this idea of um
association mapping from a non-linear
position uh uh point of view
but are there other ways for us to also
think about how to bridge the gap
between these linear models and black
box machine learning type methods
and that brought us this idea of
using neural networks where the
architecture of these neural networks
are governed by biology
okay
i mean this is work done uh that's been
co-led one paper was co-led by students
and brown cannon and
in way and is also being led by um
hugh who uh now who is um
doing his md phd at university of
chicago
and so for those who may not be familiar
with the neural network you can think
about a neural network as to me
um another version of a nonlinear model
right
um and so here's a nice fully what we
call a fully connected neural network
where you have some input layer you can
think about x1 and x2 being um
uh snips again
each of these weights or each of these
uh
input neurons are fed into hidden
neurons so you here we have our hidden
layer here we say fully connected
because
each of my inputs are then connected to
one of the neurons in my hidden layer
um
and then we have this hidden layer and
you can layer weights and then feed out
to our output layer which you then use
to make nice predictions with right
now you if you're looking at this you
can write this in a way that looks very
similar to
the non-linear regression model that i
showed before right
h is some non-linear transformation of
my inputs those have weights those feed
into some f you could think about f as
being very similar to the like the gp
learned f that we showed that i showed
you before
i can be basing about this if i want i
could put priors on the on the different
weights of my network
and i can learn things from there now
the fully connected version of this is
not necessarily interpretable because um
you know each of these weights feed
differently into x and so you it's kind
of hard to decide you know
you know what is enrichment mean for any
of these given snips right these hidden
neurons don't necessarily have any kind
of interpretation they're just
non-linear transformation that might
input data right because everything's
kind of fully connected
um and so it's hard to kind of do
association mapping here now i couldn't
theory run run rate on this model but
again we want to kind of move away from
that regime
and so
taking a step back what we do know about
biology is that um
biology is actually kind of hierarchical
in nature
and so what i mean by that is let's take
this manhattan plot as an example
uh the x-axis here will be chromosomes
again y-axis here is going to be our
inclusion probabilities this time from a
bayesian model
each of these dots here are going to be
a different snip right
um you can ignore the blue and red these
are just to show you from this study
what was previously identified were
potentially novel the key takeaway here
though is that a given you know at a
given genomic position or location i do
have some kind of annotation where i
know that uh certain genes are encoding
for that given region right certain
regions are might be energetic between
given like almost like a gene desert
right and i can kind of annotate this
across the entire genome right
um so knowing that
it's almost like we should leverage this
kind of knowledge and help have this
inform the architecture of that network
that i just showed you right
so effectively i for every uh uh for a
lot of organisms right we have some kind
of idea of where genes are which
chromosomes they are with starting in
positions they might be encoding for and
we also know which snips fall within
that given starting ending position
right
so i want to use that information to
inform what my architecture might look
like again let's look at this uh
manhattan plot at the bottom i have my
snips each of these snips have been
as you can see here uh
um annotated for a given gene
now stay with me
will be really cool to create
biologically annotated neural networks
and you can kind of see this is if i
flip this thing on its axis where i now
have naturally grouped variables
together
and from an interpretable region
i kind of have this thing that looks
like a neural network
right
groups of input variables can be grouped
together based on whether or not i know
that they are annotated for the same
genomic unit or
or for the same gene right or same
pathway or whatever the case might be
why this is really nice is this creates
a partially connected neural network
where not everything is connected to the
hidden layer you strategically connect
things based on that annotation and what
that does is it gives you
interpretability at every single scale
or every single uh layer of the model
right
now my input layers know my snips or my
variants
but my hidden layer now
are uh genes and snip sets
right and the output are phenotypes
um
and so now i have a way of
looking at a fully interpretable model
where all of my weights are connected to
a single unit that i now can do things
like variable selection on
right
and so that's what bands is all about
it's about using this partially
connected architecture to do so
so uh we start with some annotations
here we'll think about snips as being
like snip sets as meaning things like
genes and pathways i know which
chromosomes these things lie on i know
what starting in positions they are and
i know what snips fall within the
context of that thing
and i could use that to create my
partially connect network and everything
here is color coded based on um
which scale i'm looking at so my input
layer or my snips this feeds into my
snip set layer
and this feeds into the my phenotype
all right
now i can be really what's what's really
nice about this this uh
initial setup here
is i can now specify really cool priors
based on you know how i think snip level
effects might be distributed versus how
i think maybe gene effects might be
distributed right so i can think about
whether a trait has a very traditional
type of
scheme where you have snips that are
either associated or not associated like
i put like a spike and slab prior on
that or i can think about um a little
more nuanced in how snips might be
distributed if the trade is very
polygenic or not um where i have maybe
highly large effects nips maybe
intermediately if uh intermediate
effects snip so snip effects that are
maybe are small yet non-zero and then
sniff effects that are actually zero
right so that gives me a lot of room to
play with and i can tailor this based on
the architecture i believe to be true
for my trait
and so now we can specify a really nice
hierarchical model to do this so i take
my partially connected model and i can
create a really nice uh
high report bayesian non-linear
regression model um that represents this
network right so i have my my fully
specified snippet or a
phenotype layer here where the phenotype
is just a linear combination of my
hidden neurons right with their weights
and some biases i could put nice priors
for how i think those snip set effects
are distributed
and um my hidden neurons all right are
a linear combination of my input snips
right
and their weights and i can put a nice
little prior of how i think snip snip
effects might be distributive
and that gives me a really nice uh
non-linear regression model okay and now
i can do is i can then define posterior
inclusion probabilities for how i think
you know which snip
level weights are zero or non-zero and
that gives me like an enrichment score
for which i can follow through right
this model is really flexible so in in
human genetics we also really think
about um
we also really think about working with
summary statistics so if the individual
level information is not available to
you can you work with like almost like
from a meta-analysis perspective this
model also works with that if i if i
don't have access to
uh genotypes and phenotypes directly i
might only have access to
um effect size estimates from another
study and some reference panel ld matrix
um
this band's model also works with that
where instead of modeling the y variable
directly i model the effect size
estimates and then i feed in some
reference panel ld to then do the same
kind of difference
we can also do this
from a multi-phenotype perspective so
instead of just modeling one phenotype i
can also model multiple at a time and
also like i was mentioning before with
the
mega element story
leverage the correlation across traits
to to uh increase our power for
identification or association mapping in
any one given tree
and so again the band story has the same
kind of three components that i was
thinking about before right there's a
motivating probabilistic model there's a
notion of effect size like this idea
that i have one weight per uh per neuron
for which i can do classic variable
selection with and then i can also
derive inclusion probabilities which
allow me to have some uh metric that
summarizes markers
and so we use a variational em algorithm
to fit this model
um the poster the mean for each of the
weights for non-associated snips and
snip sets um
are set to zero
and we get these nice inclusion
probabilities which tell us the
probability that any one of these given
weights are um
not equal to zero right so weight so
posterior inclusion probably is closer
to one means more rich closer to zero
it's not reached at all okay and we
what's really nice is we get this at
both the snip level as well as the set
level so you can do multi-scale
inference uh simultaneously
so let me show you how this works um
we'll work with uh chromosome one from
individuals of self-identified european
ancestry in the uk biobank
um this data set has 300 349 000
individuals and 36 000 or so snips
um we're on look at chromosome 1. um
we're going to use a reference database
um where we've annotated for 19 000 uh
our 1900 genes
i'm assuming the traits in this
simulation study are uh
have a heritability or broads and
territoriality of 0.6
um but again in this in this in this
paper there are like we go over so many
different scenarios so feel free to to
look at um
and search all of these if you if you
want they're like 60 pages supplementals
of different
experiments that we run
um
one thing that's ideal here is that we
want to compare our model's efficacy on
both snip level association mapping as
well as snip set or gene level
association mapping the idea here is
that for doing things correctly
bands should be superior at both tasks
right so should i it should prioritize
causal snips well and sharp initially
prioritize
prioritize the genes that hold those
causal snips also well so we're going to
compare against methods in the field say
there are methods in the field that are
supposed to be good at either one of
those tasks
um so here's the uh snip level results
um uh
the band's model is going to be in red
and then right basically on that line is
going to be the band's model with
summary statistics instead of using uh
individual level data
sparse architecture here just simply
means there are a few snips that are
driving the association the trait and
polygenic means there are many
obviously the polygenic task is much
harder because every snip describes a
smaller and smaller piece of that that
given variation pi or that that pie
chart i was showing before with the
phenotype
you can see how competitive we are um
on on this level in both of these given
architectures
um and then also for the gene
identification task as well
um
you can actually see there's a little
bit more separation between us and these
gene level
methods
part of our future work here is
improving the runtime and the
scalability of bands so we've moved this
from just being able to run on cpus to
be much more utilized on gpus to work
with much more larger data sets with
many more features and many more
observations
and also taking in multiple phenotypes
at a time so that work will be coming
out soon
we did an appellation test which i
thought was really useful from a
reviewer this idea of how useful is it
to
have a non-linear model um in this case
can we just use elements instead and so
we ran this appalachian test where we
kind of removed different pieces of the
model to show which piece was more most
needed in order to have this high
sustained performance
um so here is this with additive
architecture um
our uh variational em scheme is um is
needed here but the thing i always like
to point to people is that blue line is
us having a um
a activation function for those hidden
neurons that's additive versus
non-additive so the red is our model not
additive
and the blue is just having an additive
um
activation function effectively just
saying non-linearities don't necessarily
matter so you can see when the
architecture of the trade is additive
sure
that doesn't necessarily mean anything
those lines are basically right on top
of each other what's really cool is that
if we include
um epistasis into the simulation of our
traits you can see how much um
how uh affected the model's performance
is by not having that hidden activation
neuron as you can see that blue line
kind of drops off so i thought that was
like a really cool thing that the
reviewers asked us to do
there are a few things that we're trying
to improve with this um band the the
variational em in our algorithm can
sometimes underestimate the snip
heritability or weights um for complex
traits and architecture so we're trying
to figure out ways to to get around this
this might mean fitting different model
uh model fitting schemes um in the
future
you can kind of see when things are just
additive on the left-hand side we're
almost perfect at this task um and as
the architecture of the trait gets a
little bit more complicated you can see
how we're kind of like downward there's
like this little downward bias this is
not surprising to us but these are
things that we're thinking about in the
future of how to make better
um
as a one last example as i'm like
running out of time
um i just want to show this how this
works in real data
so here we have uh
the framingham heart study uh for data
set one and we're also going to take a
random subset of 10 000 people to show
if we're able to replicate some of these
findings across two different data sets
um we filter these genotypes in the uk
be to have the same snips that were
genotyped and observed in the framingham
heart study
um we consider 18 000 sniff sets of a
combination of genes and anagenic
regions between those genes as our snip
sets and we're just going to show you
this example on uh on a
low density lipoprotein uh
cholesterol concentration
so here you can see the results from
bands again the really nice thing about
this you get this multi-scale view of
things so the framing of our studies at
the top uk bio banks on the bottom and
you can see that we normally get we only
have a snip level resolution but in the
box in the um
legend here we can also show which of
those genes are also enriched for that
given thing um and so the genes are kind
of listed at the top here stars are the
things that are actually replicated
across those two data sets which is
actually quite interesting because
the framing mr study actually has a
diverse set of people
involved and so um
there's further investigation that one
could take here
um but that was that was a lot of fun uh
working
in this space
and so just for the last five minutes i
would like to give you guys an idea of
like stuff they're working on in the
future um and if anyone is interested i
would love to collaborate on some of
these um
uh
some of these avenues
um
so you know the first idea for us here
is to take bands and and these kind of
like
neural network methodologies it
completely closed the gap between what
they're able to do what you're able to
do with linear models
and so we're really trying to develop
theory uh then that for like things like
for the band framework to be minimal for
genomic studies with small sample sizes
for instance um and we've also been
moving to the multi-omic uh
uh setting as well there's there's a
recent paper from
a friend ellie van allen's group uh
at data farber who recently pulled out
this method called pnet where they they
have a similar architecture and looking
at different um uh genomic modalities
and these kind of models for prediction
so really cool to see if you could do
this really nicely for like association
mapping
um
and the last thing i kind of mentioned
before was thinking about these kind of
methods in the context of shapes so what
happens when genomics summaries or
genetic information is not available to
you but you have like shape-based
information
um so i'm really interested in this
question of when can you use shape
variation
um as a proxy to study genotypic or
phenotypic variations on the bottom hand
here uh you have this brain tumor that
was reconstructed from mri scans from my
group we ran this through a neural
network and reconstructed this brain
tumor as if i had gone in and certainly
removed that individual the idea here is
to identify structural um signatures
that can be related to like the genomic
processes that create there right and so
uh we've we've been working on this idea
of
linking physical characteristics um
to you know things like the oncogene
signatures or underlying signaling
cascades that may have been activated
and if you could do that you might think
about ways of studying
shape and morphology and using that as a
proxy to then predict like uh treatment
strategies or things like that
um now that problem is really hard but
we've already made a lot of progress
here and so one one thing to kind of
pitch for those who are thinking about
some of these questions of um shape or
imaging based things
we created this thing called the sinatra
pipeline
sinatra stands for some acronym um but i
really like it because it kind of takes
all of the weird things that i do in my
lab and kind of combines them all into
like one cohesive sound um and so
sinatra takes shapes from different
species different mutational classes i
guess 3d meshes or 3d objects what it
does is it encodes these 3d objects into
like uh summary statistics um
uh using uh things from differential
geometry and topological data analysis
these summary statistics encode all the
geometry and topology in each of these
shapes
once i have these curves i can do
variable selection on these curves i can
do with any feature vector right so i
can use rate i can use something like uh
neural network where the case might be
and once i i can identify the pieces of
these curves that are our signatures
that drive the variation between these
two species
now what's really cool is once i
identify those these pieces my
transformation from shape to summary
stat is invertible so i can move from
from summary cystic back onto the
physical uh surface of these 3d objects
and i can identify the pieces of these
shapes um that are enriched for this
given uh
uh these gifted species basically
describing these are these are teeth
from from carnivores and herbivore
primates and i'm going to show i can we
can show the actual physical regions
that are that are different between
these two groups we've done this with a
bunch of different um model organisms
and things like that now we've done this
with um proteins and protein dynamics as
well as um maze roots um from different
crosses um to kind of as a predictive uh
model to to think about which process
might produce the most yield things like
that
um so that's been really fun
um
overall i really want to thank everyone
for for hanging out listening uh
hopefully i said something that might be
useful for people um this is these are
these are projects that i i love what
i've been able to do because i've got to
work with so many cool people in so many
different places uh people have been
nice and have given us money
um and uh
here are some relevant references from
the things i've talked about and um yeah
with that i'll take any questions
all right are there any questions from
folks in the audience
um hi
there um it was really cool talk thank
you thank you very much um i was
wondering when you're saying that you're
working on speeding it up uh how long
does it take to run like uh
the sort of test cases where you had
like a few thousand samples with like
tens of thousands of snips uh like how
um how much power do you need to run
that analysis yeah that's actually
that's pretty fast um so the current
version of this is is uh for a few
thousand samples and like a couple
thousand snips um so in the
uk bio bank setting we were able to run
like a hundred we ran a hundred
replicas for
uh each different setting and each of
those replicas only took like a day and
a half or something like that they're
pretty fast to run through i think our
new gpu
um implementation is even faster than
that we're thinking about larger studies
where we have like 500 000 people so
we're still working up towards that
setting but the current setting of
things i showed here are are ready to go
now
um and they they can be ran without many
resources
no that's super cool thank you and if i
can ask another question
so can you have overlapping uh sort of
gene sets or statics that's a great
question okay
um
the the short answer is yes
um the thing that we're still
investigating
is the correlation how much overlapping
between those two gene sets so
um
because of there there might be an
identifiability question here that could
throw the algorithm off
so we've been thinking about
we we just started investigating this
for for pathways where you have over
largely overlapping pathways
i'm trying to choose between the two
what the model will do in that case
is it will
most it's going to choose in the
variational em framework it's going to
choose one of those two pathways if both
of those pathways are causal
um so that means you might have your if
the mod is going to air on a larger type
2 error than a larger type one um and so
that's something that i think to think
about and so we're trying to work on how
to get around this in a fully bayesian
model what the model will do
is it'll take the it'll see those two
variables as being highly co-linear and
it'll take that inclusion probability
that it would have given to to either of
them and like break it up so you'll have
a like a delineated um
uh or or a less
uh starking uh pathway model but that is
something that i think to keep in mind
in the in the current framework and
that's a great that's a great question
um but in theory it can take these
things it's just mathematically that's
something to watch out for yeah no that
makes sense thank you and again it was
it was a really great talk thanks thanks
appreciate it
do you want to go
sure yeah lauren really appreciated it
neat and neat uh work it's wondering
have you tried doing multi-tray uh
fitting and multi-trait model
simultaneously and if you're doing that
do you have to have multiple nodes at
the gene level because you know a
particular gene
may have effects through
its differential expression and through
its protein you know
amino acid changes right and those are
two different axes of variation and
though but there's information coming
from multi traits so i'm kind of
wondering how you're thinking through
that type of uh that architecture no
that's a really good question we've okay
so we've done for the multi-trait
setting we've done it in
um a static case where i have um
sniffs and i have uh um
uh
the same thing uh the same observation
measurement different environments or or
the same set of observations models the
graphs like uh height b and mass you
want to leverage those kind of
measurement the the various the
correlational process measurements
um we have not done this in the
multi-omic
or dynamic based setting like you were
mentioning i think so in the multi-ohmic
case
one question we've been having
is how to set up the architecture that
takes advantage of some of those things
that you were mentioning
in other words do i introduce
multi-ohmic measurements at the very
beginning of the model or if i think
about it from a hierarchical standpoint
do i
introduce new pneumonic measurements at
different stages of
the layers and so we've been testing
some of those theories out
um but no we haven't done it to that
extent but that's a really that's a
really really good point that's
something i'll
uh
keep in mind and jot down to think about
a little further um and if you have diaz
happy to happy to think about them with
you
yeah happy to chat about this
our lab is asking you lots of questions
on us we're
yeah yeah nice talk i am
i was sort of thinking uh
you know we've seen some efforts uh in
the genomic prediction community to
[Music]
predict environmental or g by e effects
using things that look like essentially
kinship matrices between environments
right environmental covariance matrices
things like that but i think of
environmental effects as being
really particularly non-additive
um
and just curious if you've thought at
all about sort of ways to
kind of move beyond just genetic effects
yeah so um right so i did a so i i have
a i have a marginal epi static method
that i think um
um with this which is this idea of
shortening your search search space
among uh interactions to look at snips
that are most likely to be an
interaction that you follow up with
those so in order to give yourself a
more predictive power
oliver staple took that model and then
ran it for a g by e question the same
idea of thinking about like this idea of
marginal interactions as a as a first
investigative um
step
i've thought about taking those two
models and thinking about how to employ
those here an easy connection of how to
do that in this
particular model would be almost
introducing environmental effects to
each of those nodes i had mentioned
um
that way your
now your
hidden neurons are like the snip by
e effect that you're looking for
um we haven't done this per se but i
think that's an easy natural extension
for how to look at that um
so that's that's that's the one area
that i thought about this could be could
be useful to do
yeah thanks that's cool yeah
all right it looks like we're running
out of time so i just want to thank
lauren again for giving a a great
seminar and for any grad students or
interested postdocs that want to ask
more questions we have the after seminar
virtual lunch chat right after this
which the link should be in your emails
but also in the zoom chat
so thank you lauren and uh
bye everyone thanks so much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu